e pour nous c'est évident que la ferme
doc devait continuer à notre départ en
retraite si tu es ça faisait partie de
nos vies de nos choix quand on
s'installe est restée pour monter un
projet qui a réussi et qui devait
continuer après nous nous n'était qu'un
passage n'a transmis un outil qui
fonctionne et qui paiera nous a permis
de nous tous donc c'est un plaisir
d'installer même si c'est évident parce
que des moments difficiles aussi quand
il faut quitter son lieu de travail sans
raison will i 2 c est l outil de travail
et la maison on a on a vu ses enfants si
vous qu'il allait construire cette
maison
vous avez fait vos enfants dans cette
maison où il avait dû grandir whissell
quand on a fait la maison s'était posé
la question de bâtir en lotissement ou
sur la ferme parce qu'on pensait déjà
transmettre la ferme
bon on a choisi enfin surtout mon épouse
les consommateurs construit sa maison
sur le lieu de travail et je pense
qu'une ferme c'est vraiment un produit
c'était une réussite qu'on est bâti sur
place et
c'était dur de la quitter on savait
qu'on transmette avait une famille qui
allait retrouver un lieu de lui comme un
autre donc en fait c'était une
continuité de votre projet ce n'était
pas une rupture pour le projet c'est une
continuité pour nous ça a été une
rupture dans notre pire le champion
déménagement a été difficile pour moi
l'adaptation à la nouvelle maison et un
petit peu une sensation d'oisiveté
d'inutilité des cours mais c'est un
choix délibéré
et pourtant cette ferme ça faisait plus
d'un siècle qu'elle était dans le train
oui je crois que bon on a essayé de nos
enfants notre fils augure continuez vous
pouvez pas pour raisons de santé
je pense que nous n'avons t on à
remonter un outil qui était ancien
canton arriver mais je crois que
l'attachement familiale dans le bâtiment
travailler mais alors quels ont été les
critères qui pour vous et pour votre
femme était important pour une choix du
successeur
le premier critère qu'on a pris parce
qu'on a eu un échec sur un premier
candidat
on est parti vraiment sur le projet de
vie du candidat
c'est à dire que tous les candidats
qu'on a reçu les a reçus en pha ministre
n'a pas reçu que le candidat à
l'installation mais son conjoint ses
enfants s'ils en avaient on a vraiment
aborder le problème devenu projet
devenir un petit peu les valeurs qui
animent et si ces candidats pour
s'installer et on a vraiment les
derniers notre choix sur ces ce projet
parce qu'on a réussi la première fois il
ya une amie c'est pourquoi je crois
qu'on n'avait pas été clair au début
là on est on était parti vraiment sur la
transmission d'un outil le sens rien
mais dès hier 100 m de valeur 100 m et
on appelle des pères non plus sur une
autre chose car n'est tout de suite
discussions quand on a abordé alors
c'est sûr le prix je crois que pat on
transmet sa ferme dès le départ ferait
très clair sur ce qu'on veut sur le prix
est négociable ou pas mais accéder valls
qui sont indispensables dès le début et
si on ne part pas sur les valeurs des
gens un moment circuit sera lancé en
même temps la valeur financière avec
dalé les valeurs morales éthiques
oui tout à fait opaque je crois qu'on
peut pas faire abstraction de d2 parce
qu'on a mis dotera enfin notre âme notre
coeur dans cet outil ou la façade
derrière notre façon on sait que le
projet du sud on ne sent pas nous on
espère c'est que l'espérance que tu peux
être que ça continuera
un petit peu dans les moeurs
foulée la même morale et là ça fait
quatre ans que michael est installé vous
en pensez quoi
c'est une réussite ou pas alors moi ce
que je dis s'il fallait réécrire le
scénario on referait la même chose je
crois qu'on a et on est vraiment
contents nos stars sur le nikkei il ya
installé son épouse depuis le 1er
janvier
donc ça se déguste a choisi de
s'installer qui sont sur le même plan
avec des valeurs différentes des nôtres
c'est sûr ils sont dans la continuité de
notre projet on va dire
le projet qu'on avait démarré donc le
fait que son épouse les rejoint pour
vous c'est déjà un signe que ça marche
financièrement je crois que je suis
certain que ça marche parce que avec
michaël da dessus bien très claire donne
ce résultat
libault me dont il a absolument pas
obligés il ya une confiance mutuelle en
fête et
les fiers de ces résultats de le montrer
qui a réussi à échapper au fisc et très
bien